well it is official bts mania has just
taken over las vegas the south korean
boy band kicking off the first night of
their four night concert stop at
allegiant stadium and the atmosphere was
electric sasha loftus has been out there
all night soaking up all the excitement
and she joins us now with a look sasha
denise there is a reason they call it
the bts army the concert just let out a
couple of minutes ago and you can see
it's pretty crazy down here as tens of
thousands of people
leave that concert that they were so
excited to see now many we spoke with
tonight say this all means a lot more to
them than just music
las vegas was lit up like dynamite
friday
as bts mania descended on allegiant
stadium for the start of a week-long
permission to dance on stage tour stop
finally they are here tens of thousands
of fans wore their craziest purple gear
to welcome the south korean boy band
sensation they're coming from germany
they're coming from
singapore i mean they're just
from all over the world and many say
this means more to them than just music
quite literally i would say they saved
my life their music saved my life
opening up to share the times bts songs
have brought them back from their
darkest moments i found them right after
i had tried to
take my life and
when i found them everything was
brighter this army's love and loyalty is
unlike anything some of us in southern
nevada have ever seen they really care
about their fans and they care about
mental health and whether they came from
across the country or the world
those we spoke with say they were more
than ready i'm so happy that we finally
have something where people are actually
finally coming back to vegas to get it
let it roll
bts will perform here again tomorrow
night the next friday and next saturday
those shows all sold out as you can see
here if you are not heading out to one
of these concerts i would avoid the area
because traffic is quite a mess and will
be quite a mess for a little while
longer reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now